the gift that keeps on giving he's Shay
and Irving as his Dallas Cowboys look
very impressive they survived one more
game and then you get a zekiel elliot
back Shea how you feeling today 29
design runs 30 pass attempts Danny it's
about damn time
is that the ginger figured it out yeah
you should be feeling good here
I'm not here's my fear Danny okay I
think it's reasonable to describe me as
an emotionally fragile person true
hey if the Cowboys get this close to the
playoffs and shoot themselves in the
foot I don't know if I'm ever gonna come
back from that Danny well what do you
mean by that not come back from that I
mean like you know a rehab oh I don't
want to stop you back in 30 days I don't
want to see that happen there but again
yeah okay Green Bay loses Detroit loses
Atlanta loses too and can't walk through
the playoffs okay I mean it's it's like
it's not gonna be easy pretty damn easy
to me Danny this is a possibility yeah
yeah that's all I'm the one that told
you hey you guys can win out you told me
you couldn't I remember that about the
quarterback controversy brewing up in
New Jersey huh what's the quarterback in
conjurer's Geno Smith man you saw what
swing blade was doing on the field that
was downright illegal what do you know
in Manatee right no that would neither
is their future their it'd be nice if
they put in Davis Webb but it didn't
matter
I mean that that game all of a sudden
you know the Giants are leading and then
the Cowboys just never stopped
[Music]
no dak Prescott had a big game passing
one the best passing game of his career
and it doesn't exist without the
play-action Danny come on we don't need
to go through this again I know I
realized that but you're gonna get
you're gonna get Zeke back play actions
back you're gonna go to Seattle you're
gonna have to win that game and then
you're gonna enter in Philly the ginger
and Phil yeah yeah you try something
like Jesus is a Cowboys fan again yeah
and then all of a sudden if there's no
Carson wins you all you gotta do is beat
Nick Foles
that's it
I don't know I'm getting confused and
scared Danny it's a scary time for me
all right well you got to win and we're
happy for you
whatever thank you Schanke che che
doesn't know how to be in a good mood
like he's nervous to be in a good mood
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]